you said i fully believe that if you
know noam chomsky and oprah went free to
innovate at the highest level you have
to
learn how to be fully focused i 100
agree with that part so let's talk about
somebody that's right now you know got
all the distractions we all got they got
one of these they got an ipad they got
kids they got family they got you know
their jobs are trying to get aside the
hustle they got you know all these other
things that they're doing
and they're having a hard time stay
focused what is the basic formula for
one to stay focused so there's lots of
things and i go through dozens in the
book but i'll give you an example of one
that
really helped me in my life and i think
will help people in that position
so i learned a lot about the science of
something that called flow states
everyone listening will have experienced
a flow state a flow state is when you're
doing something that's really meaningful
to you and you just get into it and
you're in the zone and it's like time
falls away and your ego falls away and
you're just in it the way one rock
climber put it is a flow state is like
when you feel like you are the rock
you're climbing right so for me it would
be when i write for someone else it
might be when they make bagels or they
do brain surgery or they play the guitar
but a flow state is really important for
attention for two reasons a flow state
is the deepest form of attention you can
bring right when you're in a flow state
you are deeply focused and a flow state
is the easiest form of attention once
you get into it it's not like memorizing
facts for an exam
it's like you know like oh [ __ ] how do i
do this you're in it you don't it's not
even you don't even have to want to be
in it there's no effort involved you're
just it's called a flow state because
you are just flowing right so i wanted
to understand given this is the easiest
form of attention once you're in it and
the deepest [ __ ] how do we get more of
this i went to interview professor
mahali cheek sent me hai you have no
idea how long it took me to learn how to
say that who is the leading ex was that
sadly
sadly died recently but he was the
leading expert on flow states he studied
them for over 50 years he's the man who
coined the phrase
and he discovered a [ __ ] ton of stuff
about this i think there's three that
would really help the person you're
talking about three key facts
if you want to maximize your chances of
getting into a flow state and there's no
guarantee but if you want to maximize
your chances you've got to do three
things
firstly you've got to narrow down to one
goal
if you're trying to do more than one
thing at a time you'll never get into
flow choose one goal
secondly it's got to be a goal that's
meaningful to you right
if it's not meaningful you won't get
into flow and thirdly it will really
help if you choose a goal and this is
counter-intuitive at first it will
really help if you choose a goal that's
at the edge of your comfort zone at the
edge of your abilities so let's say
you're a medium medium talent rock
climber right
you don't want to just try and climb
over your garden wall it's not going to
get you into flow
equally you don't want to try and
suddenly climb like you know one of
those mountains in colorado that's
really high you'll just [ __ ] yourself
you want to choose a rock face that is
slightly higher and harder than the last
rock face you climbed
so if you do these three things
choose one goal make it a meaningful
goal make it one at the edge of your
abilities you massively maximize your
chances of getting into a flow state and
being able to do that deep form of
attention but there's lots of other
things that we can do i recommend really
long social media breaks i take half the
year completely off social media and i'm
so much more productive in those six
months than i am in the six months when
i'm on it um i sleep much more than i
used to
i mentioned the k safe i lot i bind
myself in i lock that [ __ ] away i you
know because i know that i'll crack if i
just leave it sitting there um but
there's one about kids that i think is
really important as well because in a
way if we're not building the baseline
of focus and attention for children
you know this is going to be an even
bigger problem 20 30 years from now
you're saying kids to get into a flow
state or no just generally for children
and attention generally before we get to
kids i know we're going to spend time on
that i want to talk about that flow
state because we have a lot of
entrepreneurs on our channel people that
are in business some of the things you
were talking about
they have a very much
similarity to what we talk about here
what you talk about here is rather than
doing a handful of tasks gets you know
focused on that and what we call that is
being a specialist being versus being a
jack of all trades it's the first thing
i thought of it's like okay if you want
to be good at something focus on one
thing and be great at that one thing
everyone wants to talk about having you
know
double sources of income and like
multiple uh incomes coming in it's like
no let's just get one income solidified
and then number two
you said what
um meaningful goal
so for that they say you have to work
about something that you're passionate
about you don't have to you don't have
to you know pat's passion is baseball
cards but that wasn't he's or baseball
he wasn't gonna be a baseball player or
collect baseball cards for a living i
don't understand american sports no
matter how long i live
but basically you know choose something
that you know
you'll specialize in that you're
passionate about and then last but not
least your comfort zone will kill you
push yourself to the point where you're
like
i don't know if i really want to do that
but i'll go for it but so it seems to be
an analogous to to basically
the business stuff that you talked about
did you did you did you kind of pick
that up when you said i mean and tyler
just pulled something up david if he can
show this
uh how to take bill gates's think week
to recover from life
every year he takes a week bill gates he
goes to a cabin no phone no laptop no
nothing and you think about guys like
jeff bezos
richard branson all the
multi-billionaires that are innovators
what do they do every morning they wake
up and they meditate they don't have
their phones they don't have their
eyeballs
or they read they sit they think well
there's speculation that a friend of
them would meet him at this thing but
that's a different conversation
but let me let me go i i i think i uh
there's a story though i want to hear it
but there is a story there tell me
offline but i'm no longer married
what i like about this is i fully uh
subscribe to this i
you know i sometimes would say hey i'm
going over here i'm going to be here for
a day
don't bother me if you need to get a
hold of me here's my room number here's
this well what you said the story about
when you went to harvard business school
he says don't touch your phone don't
worry about it we got this thing we're
going to take care of it just how hard
was that for you to do i'm
mathematically impossible
you do not regret it do you oh was one
of the best things i did but this is
this is why yeah you know it's so
interesting about touching your phone
the average person touches their phone 2
617 times a day right
and it used to be 150 just 10 years ago
i know it's massively exposed number 2
617 it's probably higher now because
that was that research was done before
so you think about you exactly right the
reason the subtitle for the book is and
how to think deeply again is for exactly
this reason right because we were
talking before about some of the
benefits right and there are real
benefits from the speedy way in which we
live it's very important to acknowledge
that
but one of the costs is when you go
really fast you lose depth and you in
all innovation and all originality and
all creativity come from depth right so
what happens is we're constantly living
in in the shallows in these in in these
um
this kind of manic mode so if you don't
make space and we've got to be honest
with people you know the way professor
joel nick who i mentioned before one of
the leading experts on children's
attention problems put it to me is he
said we live in what he called an
attentional pathogenic environment which
means this is an environment where it's
very hard for people to do the right
thing and focus deeply the number of
people who can do what bill gates does
is very small right the number of people
who can do what what what we're
proposing currently is small and the
only thing i think
in this whole conversation i think the
only thing i've disagreed with and i
understand why you say it because part
of me thinks it is you said before i
can't see why i wrote it down but you
said something like
this is never gonna change right you're
gonna always be in an environment that's
gonna be and of course there's always
gonna be some distractions you'll write
about that there's always gonna be a
human struggle between you know you can
go back to monks a thousand years ago
and they still struggled a little bit
with well i could be distracted by this
thing or i could do this other thing
but we're living an environment now that
is hugely damaging our attention right
um and there are and i do think we've
got to understand that
because a we can protect ourselves and
our kids better when we understand it
but b because the environment can change
right think about leaded paint right
when we were kids we were exposed to
lead that damaged our attention right
damages everyone's attention you could
have said then
i'm sure you wouldn't have but you
someone could people did say that oh you
know this is always going to be a
problem right how are we ever going to
deal with it but actually we did deal
with it right and for all of the other
12 factors that we're talking about
there are very practical solutions so
let's think about the ones that relate
to kids in particular because i'm
fascinated by so we can look at the
school system but set that aside for a
minute right there's a huge change that
i think we're really well suited to see
people our age so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]